we just we just
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com you don't have to be a
freeloader your whole life
the good news is that you can support
this show and the fight by buying some
really cool clothes.com
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um that's good nice it's just what i
need with my throat cancer tastes ah
i don't know if i have throat i have
something going around here we actually
have some interns who aren't in because
of a throat thing no code i got a test
but uh ever since i did that thing the
whitmer impression remember like oh
my throat so if there's an ear nose and
throat doctor out there i don't know if
it's polyps
it's a curse man she cursed you well i
know i know you know i haven't spent any
time with catherine zeta jones so
no you don't have a douglas don't you
love how michael just
michael douglas when he got throat
cancer he immediately blamed it on uh
performing you know services on his wife
like way to throw her under the butt and
it wasn't even necessary
is this yeah she's like family for her
yeah that's right she's like i got hpv
like crazy
still waiting on zorro four hey uh
really glad to be with you today sorry
we're late we had to put together
something for you
as it relates to january 6th and the
black lives matter riots and because
there's a different standard to which
we're held with youtube we had to do a
lot more blurring of
everything that we showed you was
available on youtube not blurred but you
know
we have to do it because uh yeah for the
same reason that other people like
hunter biden you know they can uh not
that i want to
no no but he can repeatedly drop the end
bump and by the way let me just clarify
we're gonna be talking about hunter bye
today
i don't think he's a racist i don't
think joe biden is a racist i really
don't
i want i don't think he should be
canceled i think he should be canceled
because he's a serial pedophile
i agree there's like other grounds
there's levels yeah there's multiple
levels here yeah doing your best nwa
impression
intercourse with kids yeah a little bit
lower down in the totem pole there
you'll be talking about all that oh by
the way it is your last uh opportunity
to
go to crowdershop.com and get your
father's day merch can you see this
which one is the best the change my mind
is this destiny whatever i like this one
this is a fight
like hell yeah and uh for people who
missed yesterday we talked about our
childhood fighting stories uh on mug
club hey gerald a how are you sir i'm
well how are you
throat cancer how are you quarter black
garrett i'm doing good good i'm ready to
read it
we need to make sure that you keep that
hood pass because someone needs to read
hunter's texts that's true
that's true and dave landa how are you
sir ahoy i'm good
i uh also have a touch of the throat
cancer so i think it might be allergic
to passing around staying away from
hoping that something allergies mine are
always like that though i always got a
throat problem
you're an allergy yeah dave you are such
a disease
i like girls with diseases you're what
the french call
it all right so uh i have a lot to talk
about we're going
we are going to be comparing january
because obviously right now january 6th
is in the media look uh i don't
an insurrection means that people have
to plan something together
coordinate and execute i think we're
getting a little loose with the
terminology i still think anyone
committed crimes like trespassing if
anyone actually did bring a weapon and
use a deadly weapon of course those
charges should be brought
um we don't know that that's the case
right no guns found
so we'll talk about that and compare it
to the black lives matter riots i think
we need to keep this in context about
hunter biden we'll be talking about him
as well
but first new york times i believe a
writer commentator
uh but she's on msnbc mara gray uh
said this is making the rounds and i
think it's a perfect sort of
encapsulation
of the fundamental difference of a world
view between
conservatives and leftists and people to
prove
yep yep yes yes i want a really clear
dividing line
in permanent sharpie especially when she
says something like this that she was
disturbed
by dozens and i want to be clear when i
first read this i thought this is
clickbait from conservatives right
outrageous porn
surely she didn't say that she was um
disturbed
by the american flag no she did i think
as long as they see americanness
as the same as one with whiteness no you
do
this is going to continue we have to
figure out how to get
every american a place at the table in
this democracy
but how to separate american-ness
america from whiteness you're talking
until we at a table
on a national newspaper talk about that
this is really going to continue i was
on long island this weekend i like her
sister macy better dear friend
and i was really disturbed i saw you
know dozens and dozens of pickup trucks
with
uh you know uh explicatives against joe
biden
uh on the back trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
okay now a lot of people just there is
some you know outrage
oh geez i just wouldn't mention hey
buddy this one full lollipop can i say
[ __ ] is that a violation
you're fine let me talk about this
really quickly
this shows the fundamental difference in
world view
where she said this means this is my
country it's our country
it's not yours that's what she sees when
she sees an american flag
no that's you copy pasting your
exclusive racism to other people
people put up the american flag because
they are saying not this is my country
they're saying
i love this country
that's what that means i love this
country and here's an irony too where
she
i know what they'll say right they used
to say oh defund the police we love this
country but we need to improve it
well look the veil is off yeah you hate
america we understand this and i've said
this for a long time
we actually were doing a segment but
because it was a problem because of
addresses
i said if you see an american flag if
you see it at a house
they're conservative they're republican
yeah highly likely
yes it is but we just you know it's
tough to do with someone's home address
we're just
go and ask them but i've been saying
this for a long time
and what she is saying here i know what
they'll say they'll say oh okay you know
we love this country but it's just
it's systemically flawed and uh you know
so we have problems with it and
and you don't know what that's because
you're a white republican
and you have a seat at the table hold on
a second that's a self-defeating point
do you see what she is implying here
yeah you're right a lot of those flags
i will agree with your premise probably
from republicans maybe not all white
but let's assume because this country is
majority white probably a lot of white
republicans
under a biden harris administration
that means that people who have no voice
at the top level right now at the
national level right they have
a president and vice former vice
president and president
who are against everything they stand
for and they still
say this is the greatest country in the
world you have everything you could
possibly want
you've gotten the people in office who
you want and you're still offended by
the flag
it's just like you know it's such it's
such a great litmus test i agree with
you
kind of like i agree with democrats when
they were saying well we can stop more
in the mask but i want people to think
i'm republican
exactly exactly for the longest time we
were saying
the masks are a political identifier
it's a point and then you say huh my
mask is my political identifier
yes we're saying the same thing i have
been saying for years and we've known
this for years
patriotism the american flag is
inherently
a conservative value it's inherently a
conservative icon
and now you're saying the american flag
is inherently conservative oh right just
because you've been trying to make it a
synonym for white supremacy
so yeah i love it when that veil gets
lifted exactly how in the world do you
consider the american flag to be a
symbol of white supremacy
it's the flag that unites this country
it's the flag that people are killed
overseas just for having on their
sleeve right right like how in the world
can you say that this person and other
prominent
liberals chimed in and said yes
certainly that person's probably you
know like an [ __ ] is what they said
sorry i'm just quoting them
and uh and i think racist or white
supremacist i'm like right how in the
world no you are for posting this
you're saying because hundreds of years
ago there was slavery therefore yeah i
hate this country
and then you have people going you know
what right now we have a horribly
corrupt administration
we've shut down our economy we've we've
infringed on our basic constitutional
rights
and we still believe that this country
is worth saving that is a different
worldview folks
and it's very clear by the implication
there why do you think it's so much more
likely that an american flag
flies alongside a maga flag than say a
rainbow flag
look if you have kids let them leave but
i've always said this if you see a
rainbow flag you almost never see an
american flag on that car
or on that house you can't love this
country and also suck dick
i don't understand that i don't
understand well you can
but they just don't we'll get to a clip
of barack obama i hate to be the word
police but it's not
explicative it's exciting and also this
is also the same woman who said that 500
million dollars could give every person
in this country a million dollars yeah
michael bloomberg campaign when he spent
that so i'm not holding her to a very
high standard here well also that
rainbow flag exists because of the
freedom this country offers yes and i
think that needs to be said
why saudi arabia let me know what
happens yeah fly it next to the at the
if they had one the hamas embassy really
it's just just a hut and a great
they're going to want to show you the
top floor of the building and then a
quick way down
okay let's find out them you guys let me
know the best thing you
look comment have you always known don't
you kind of know
if you're at a grocery store and you see
someone with a flag pin
it's almost like they've drawn half the
christian fish
basically under the air of roman
persecution right pretty close
that's pretty close we've always known
this as conservatives and they've always
said no you don't have a monopoly on
patriotism we love this country we just
want to change everything it's about
all the things that made us unique you
know freedom rugged rugged individualism
not having a
systemic socialism not having a monarch
but we want to change all of that we
want to have an elite system and
centralized government okay well then at
a certain point
you don't love this country and that's
fine just say it when you're running
look republicans we don't have to lie
when running for national office
you're right maga maga it offends you
make a
greatest country on earth right if i
have to hear another rascal flatt
song or i'm proud to be an american
that's why i don't go to cpac anymore
it's a little too much
but yeah they're genuine about it when
you run
you have an american flag kinda right
you you kind of say you're pro women and
then say pregnant persons but you have
to hide it
because you know that once you get into
office you have to admit that you did
everything this country is about
that is what this war is about right now
this
figurative war for information if you
guys have never seen it
this clearly uh also hey by the way you
can follow me on instagram
yeah at lyder earthquater apparently i'm
on tech talk i do not manage that i
believe
communist chinese uh representative oh
that's good uh
and uh it's a live show monday through
thursday 10am eastern that's the best
way you can tune in
mug club youtube or rumble uh because
notifications don't always work
okay so uh let's also oh this is another
one did you get did you see this kamala
harris clip with lester holt oh boy oh
yes
this was nice yes i am
oh yeah yeah that's something that's
formal yes you've asked me to read the
show map and i am pretending i did
no i i looked into the words yes lester
holt uh holt still don't know
i don't know like is he is he like is he
relative to dan bongino
i don't know i don't know i don't know
he could the point is he could fit in
anywhere
it's close you could use him to sell any
kind of a tire
and i'd buy it right he's just he's just
generically ethnic enough so that you
can use him
and he doesn't uh doesn't intimidate
white people he morphs she doesn't
offend
yes he's a racimorph yeah he's like one
of those cars that it
like a hyper colored shirt yes exactly
you look at him in one angle
yeah another more of a more of a
reflective
chrome uh so yesterday an interview with
lester kamala harris claimed that she
went to the border oh come on
and then and i respect lester holt for
this
called her on it yeah and she's so here
it's not just about the fact that the
sort of outrage point you see from the
right they go look look she's
no it's the fact that when you watch
this she is shocked
that someone pushes back oh yeah this is
the story right now
people in this administration saki you
look at joe biden
they are so surprised when someone
pushes back like that old kung fu master
remember you said the death touch if you
watch this video
and he fights the basic chinese mma guy
and you start doing this and the guy
just punches him once and he's like
oh i bleed
it's a great video we'll show it behind
the table we'll show it for mug club
members afterwards it's one of my
favorite of all time
uh let's watch this kamala harris saying
she went to the border then immediately
uh retracting
just quickly put a button okay do you
have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole
this whole this whole thing about the
border we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't
know i don't understand the point that
you're making you're
i know republicans have certainly come
at you on this but democratic
congressman cuellar
has a border district has said to the
you and the president come
you can't see this and i care about
what's happening at the border
i look i just i've never been there i
don't understand the point oh
well let me clarify it for you you're a
lying liar who lies
what you oh i think i think hold on you
guys ran on this though yeah
i just want to make sure i think you're
a little hazy kamala um
you just said you've been to the border
okay yeah follow with me
uh i'm saying you have not
your floor well i've not been to europe
botswana
iceland iceland still on the list i'm
pretty sure she's been to europe though
yeah well no it's like we don't share a
border with europe we also don't have an
immigration problem from europe you're
also not in charge of fixing
the problem with our border with europe
you are with mexico
well not really point that's currently
she's been put in charge by the time you
guys should put in charge it's more
figurative
i thought it was a figurehead position
your head sorry not figured
i had no idea i was supposed to do
anything
like go there i'm just waiting for my
place in line
yes any minute now yes hold on a second
i have to butter the west wing stairs
yes
oh whoopsie daisy sir you see joe biden
pause every time he goes up the stairs
to air force one and like look at each
step
double check like she did it to me once
i'm not going to fall for it again
she's slipping a 20 to his allergist and
just opening bags of peanuts
this gets hit with a pain can on air
force one
i'm up here you big stupid horse's ass
hey
hey former vice president joe you give
up or you're thirsty for more
giant like huh i'm a gold tooth
i have a tarantula i got hit by a cicada
seriously
i'll make she's basically running
running for office that's really what
she's doing and so the
safest think about this she's mirroring
what joe biden did when he ran for
office oh yeah
he just hit out and did nothing and so
she's going right 20 24.
that's my shot if i hide out buy my time
do nothing
i have a better chance of winning
because if i do anything
people don't like me yeah she's doing
nothing
badly though because people don't like
her and she's still doing nothing yeah
it's not working
people pete butt cake is like hey how
about you go out there and uh do
something
yeah post we'll post it so that everyone
can see it do something the america
should see more of you kamala you're
great we need more was one of your
main promises that's the problem yeah
right we're gonna fix the border
who's gonna be in charge of that i don't
know i'm gonna put her in charge well is
she ever gonna go there well i don't
think so
probably not she'll say she did oh good
enough for me all right it's a
it's a short flight
flew over the border to go to those
countries you went do you
stopped all the way back you could have
just looked down and been like well i
saw it yeah
exactly yeah she's just on the way to
guadalajara she's like oh hi
mexico bye um all right welcome in
guatemala so let's talk about this this
is something that uh i know you have to
be really careful because i even think
with like guidelines and stuff on
youtube yeah
you have to you you i don't even know if
you can mention january 6th and not say
that it was the worst insurrection in
our time
so look geez let me be really clear
about something here anyone who
committed an
actual crime on january 6th should be
charged
uh ultimately and convicted of that
crime absolutely trespassing obviously
misdemeanor
uh if there's actual assault assault in
many cases a misdemeanor
i just believe that the and if anyone
actually brought a deadly weapon and
used it
of course yeah to be charged with that
crime you know i just want that same
standard to be applied to
january 6th and the black lives matter
riots yeah right
i will do i'm totally open to an
investigation january 6th
if you investigate black lives matter
and the source of the funding because
we're talking about way more damn anyway
i'll get to those stats in a second
but this is one of those things i think
everyone else is sort of tiptoed around
where you either have extremists who
say nothing happened at all and then you
have people who say it was the worst
insurrection worst uprising most violent
event of our time
um i don't think either of those are
true
right yeah but sort of like we've talked
about the the vaccine the code vaccine
look the standard that you have to use
is
how does it compare to other vaccines
not how does it compare to covid
right that's the standard when people
are making these or they're discussing
the issue
in the medical community because there's
a standard right you sort of have to
have
okay this is a standard bear right here
that's our that's sort of our our
starting point
and i think that's what we need to do
here with the january sixth uh incidence
can anyone else agree that that's that's
a fair approach i'm trying to be as
fair-minded as i can
but still if you watch media cnn
and uh they're they're just hysterically
covering
january 6th some republican lawmakers
are following trump's example
trying to rewrite what happened on
january 6
for instance by calling the attackers
quote peaceful patriots
this morning we were getting our first
look at a new senate report
that's awaiting the significant security
issues that unfolded before and during
the january 6 attack on the capital
you know as an american i went there to
advocate for
uh for this commission for neckties
which i believe is necessary
really to get to the root cause of
january 6.
donald trump's role in the ride in fact
senate democrats even avoided using the
word
insurrection to describe the
insurrection
okay uh really quickly look at this
right now on cnn this just happens to be
going online
right now right now lawyer writer was
his writer argues he felt threatened by
hero officer
uh jensen's initial attraction to q and
so they're trying to associate with q
anon look oh of course let me be really
clear i'm sure there were some people
there of course
who were who were uh if you look cuenon
is idiotic to me it was so proven
verifiably false okay
it has nothing to do with people who
voted for donald trump the hundreds of
thousands of people who were there who
were peaceful
patriots and certainly the people who
donald trump identified as his
supporters saying
peacefully make your voices heard so you
know and by the way really quickly if
you have kids
watching right now i would uh advise you
to probably have them leave the room
because we are going to show side by
side the absolute worst footage from the
january 6th riots
the worst possible footage side by side
with uh the black lives matter
riots and the ant for ride so i just
want to warn you um it's not that we're
trying to
but i don't think it's age-appropriate
not a trigger warning i just don't want
nine-year-olds watching it because it
disturbed me
absolutely um they wanted a 911 style
commission to investigate the january 6
riots
republicans filibustered it yeah so what
what they want to do with the filibuster
yeah
all of a sudden yeah or all of the
things they were huge fans when 50
something percent i think was 48
of them used it to uh to block civil
rights
now it's like why what is that wait a
second you want to block a bias
commission again
i think that you could have a deal if we
talk about bipartisan guarantee
republicans would sign on to it if you
say also
same commission to black lives matter
and to the right it's a deal i'd take
tomorrow absolutely
and why do you think they're doing this
stephen there are multiple
investigations that are ongoing right
now in fact the report that they're
citing
was an investigation into what happened
on january 6th does that do does anyone
know the name of the
the officer who the only person who
killed anybody ash
ashley about it no no no by the way i
want to be clear i'm not saying that
that was i don't we don't even know
if that was a bad shot i just want to
know i want an investigation
to tell us here's why it happened right
like every other shooting that we've had
to cover over the last two years
who shot who i mean do you really need a
multi-million dollar or billion
trillion dollar rounding here at this
point yeah to find out one person shot
somebody who
because we have these reports we have
these investigations
it was like with uh brett kavanaugh was
when he invested well you're just an
investigation well we needed another one
another one we needed to take longer
you've done several
i mean we have her saying it happened so
let's do this yeah
yeah that's why i was like well they
don't call it an insurrection even
though it was an insert i'm like well no
you just can't define it you're
calling it an interruption you didn't
call it a riot all summer either
no yeah you called it mostly peaceful
while someone's
grand marquis was on fire behind you you
said
teenagers were mostly peaceful protests
yes i don't like grandma
don lemon said boys well babe yeah
so look let me give you some quick
snapshots here before you show the video
footage because i
i really think this is something that i
wish was out there and it's not
uh again send your kids away
riots two billion dollars in property
damage that was by the way
just up until june 2020 okay two billion
dollars all of them
you can't find those numbers anymore
really there's no updated number
if i were to guess probably four billion
yeah
june 2020 at least double the summer of
at least double and that was a low
estimate when we're just talking about
insurance claims and actually talking
about
um what government can observe again all
of our sources are available at
loudoutcrider.com
uh the capital damage was 1.5 million
that's the newest estimate
down from the original estimate of 30
million just to keep clear with the
black lives matter right the estimate
went
uh it went uh maybe half a billion
a billion two billion and they stopped
and then
it stopped and now with the capital
right it goes 30 million
uh 20 1.5 and it stops
just just look at the trends again we
have to compare the two of these to be
fair
uh i have a number here actually so the
black lives matter rights cost
in june 2020 1 33
more ah so that's a lot more people say
more
black lives matter over a thousand
officer casualties they're saying
casualties include severe injury and
death uh capital only one person was
killed ashley babbitt by an officer
we don't know about him not even saying
it was an unjustified shooting i don't
know other four who died uh including
sicknick we were told was beat in the
head with the fire
well that's not true right died of
natural causes um
and epstein didn't hang himself yes and
epstein did not hang himself we say that
on here
i don't know what weekends but if look
the footage will just go out for 12
minutes and 42 seconds that's true
wonderful standard that was a mostly
peaceful uh
response nothing on hunter biden on cnn
of course
nothing don't you remember when they
found the computer there wasn't any
coverage either
yeah it's like guys you know what look a
guy a sex guy has sex with kids
yeah you know what you say illegal i say
fun time with a niece
so and here's something you'll also
never see okay black lives matter before
we get to the
what you see the destruction there was
destruction on january 6th yes
not anywhere near 1 33 less as of june
20th
but um well the people that got in were
ants at a picnic and i'll say right
yes here's something that is important
to note
most of the people were let in willingly
a lot of people don't know this because
they'll never show you this
now this is in other words it's more so
the equivalent to people
who uh break through the gates at like
you know at a led zeppelin
concert yeah at a van halen reunion
right because they're trying to get
front seats
they're allowed in that venue but
they're tr so they were allowed in the
venue of the capital we need to be clear
about that doesn't mean that once
they're
in there they didn't then of course
break the law right but that's very
different from
remember anyone who lives in a city
remember all the doors were barricaded
wood panels over every single window
very very different from that and
all right come on in just you know don't
get too rambunctious so let me show you
this as a matter of fact just as a
perfect example
even you'll watch this clip even the q
anon shaman says
let's keep it peaceful and you see a
capital capital officer i believe black
yes say hey i don't agree with you but i
respect respect to
your right to do it as they walk right
past wow let me know if you've ever seen
this before real quick
police are squabbling with protesters oh
there we go
as they're being waved on
here's where the guy says it watch
you can disagree with it respect it
the insurrection had door guys and a
metal detector
they got luscious peacefully
like our first amendment allows gather
more americans under the condition that
they will come and gather peacefully to
discuss what needs to be done
to save our country and show us no
attacking no assault
remain
now is that just the guy's voice or is
he permanently doing a grover voice and
character yeah
it's definitely it's a little bit of uh
what was the trashcan guy
oscar yeah oscar we have to peaceably
assemble
it's almost like what's that i just
forget bruce wayne ordering coffee
i would like a sweet sorry like a soy
latte
oops uh i don't have the mask on the
eyes so i just say that
it's it's all that guy's fault let's be
honest i think i didn't show up with his
dumb horns we wouldn't even be talking
about this
that's the least surprising thing about
him is his voice and my point is you can
say hey
that's someone who is there who is
invited in willingly by the capitol
officers saying
everyone we need to make our voices
peacefully heard
do you really think it's white supremacy
to call that person a peaceful patriot
yeah that's that was basically a guided
tour by a seth rogen look-alike
yeah one of the people in politics said
i can't remember the guy's name but he
said it looks like more like a tour
he was pointing to that kind of video
right and we'll show you video of other
stuff that was
so i want to be clear so now this is the
footage that i want to show you because
this is something that the media will
not show you
footage side by side here of the worst
possible footage we can find from
january 6. this actually came from the
house impeachment managers
just to be clear i wanted to find the
absolutely
most severe footage of january 6 so you
can see the worst of it
and juxtaposed that with just some
footage
from the riots that took place over the
last year because we couldn't fit it all
in
and i i just want you and genuinely the
best thing you can you know
comment below i don't look
people have blind spots if i have a
blind spot and we think that these are
actually comparable
and that the january 6 riots deserve 10
times the air coverage some people have
estimates as high as 20.
yeah wow of these riots uh
let me know kids leave the room here you
go january 6th
summer of love
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
they're
come on stay with me og og
best zone there's been yet another
shooting early this morning
top security shot at those people in the
jeep after they ran
um into the barricades here so there's
another group they're meeting
with there and then they'll be moving in
a few minutes so be ready
take the clip out and put it back in no
one's gonna like
thank you
oh gee come on stay with me og og stay
with me
stay with me og stay with me o.g come on
o.g
come on o.g you don't remember that was
uh
officer david dorn black man yes now i'm
not saying all off
sorry i have to have a lozenge in my
throat here right now michael douglas
i'm not saying that all officers are
heroes but certainly an off-duty
one who showed up to help his community
and stop someone else from being robbed
that was officer david jones for people
who don't remember because
we have such short memories that was a
long time police officer
in missouri black man his entire life
who created and ran programs
to help underprivileged youth and he
showed up that night
because a friend called whose shot was
being uh
torn down i don't remember if he was
being burned down and looted
looted yeah and he was shot dead in the
street
and there's a lot of that there are a
lot of deaths at the rallies over the
summer
yeah and they're under counted but
you're still looking at dozens all
sources available at request.com
so just one thing haven't seen it
anywhere else
you guys let me know hey if i've got a
blind spot if january 6th is
because statistically it's not no but if
you feel it's worse
in spirit great okay well and you're not
excusing the people that acted up at the
insurance we're condemning them exactly
there's any ambiguity about our
statements
if you broke the law on january 6 you
should be arrested you should be tried
and if you were guilty you should be
convicted
sorry and if you were committing arson
and serious felonies
yeah over the course of this really this
entire year adding to the
well two billion dollars in damage is
just by june 2020 likely four billion
now you should also be arrested and not
catch and release
yeah and we were begging people over the
summer we were begging our leaders and
politicians in these communities to say
hey guys stop what you're doing
begging you and you wouldn't even
acknowledge that this was going on you
wouldn't even acknowledge that there
were officers that one in in chicago
where the lady
is being dragged by her hair into the
mob to be beaten mercilessly and the
cops around him
are trying to grab her yeah it's just
it's bone chilling and we were saying
guys you've got to say something to stop
him what did maxine waters and kamala
harris
and everybody else do she was on her way
she was gone
yeah they encouraged it they said of
course they're going to be in the
streets when they get louder kamala
harris
she said this is the new normal yeah
it's going to continue and it should
continue by the way it's the same lady
who just
said that she had been to the border
yeah just to be clear she flew over it
yeah she said
liar was it not saying she just said
it's good to not be flying spirit
she looks like a stewardess on spirit
yes doesn't she yeah where the answer is
always no
before you hey could i get it no
angry could i just could i just get a
water you guys you could get water my
ass
okay i'll just have nothing okay so
um let's go to hunter biden now uh uh
yeah sorry i know it's a change tone but
yes it's quite a shift yeah i know but
look it's important to do hunter biden
uh
and this is like it is important it
shouldn't be a
should it be a national story not
necessarily the story here is that
nobody cares on the left whereas
remember there were rumors
once upon a time that maybe donald trump
had said the n-word
right oh one of the uh apprentice
outright yeah that may be the reason
that bezos tried to get the rights
to the rushes to the footage yeah so um
this is why it matters because there are
rules for thee
and not for me to be clear i do not
think that hunter biden or joe biden
do we all agree i don't think either of
them are racists i think they've
accidentally
[Music]
oh
okay here we
[Music]
okay here go go
[Music]
apologize
[Music]
okay
[Music]
me
uh
oh yeah
here we go okay here we go
[Music]
here we go
would you have yes well it depends if
you're one of the
one of hunter biden's kids it could be a
flipper yeah it's true you don't want to
be limbed but we brushed that one under
the rug don't we
yeah well we brushed them all into the
rug hey where is hunter buying the kids
are they from strippers or a family
member flipper family member okay
there it is that's the tell there all
right angela do we have a couple of yeah
let's read a couple of chats before we
move on here
steve alden wants to know question
crowder how do you think that satire has
helped your critical thinking
oh you know what that's an interesting
question i think dave will have some
thought on this there's also
an important differentiation between
satire and parody a lot of people think
they're
they're not same thing at all yeah um
you know parody is a direct parody for
example like
like weird owl you know just be an
airplane yeah or you're doing a direct
parody
oh we're back we're back now is it the
same stream there's a whole new stream
it's the same stream okay it's the same
stream all right uh
well you know we'll get to that question
later hello youtube hey hello youtube
sorry about that
technical issues that seem to occur
almost exclusively with us
you never got me down youtube never and
by the way yes you are correct people
who are wondering where is yesterday's
stream
it is not on youtube we're probably
gonna need to see that picture again
just to make sure yeah i'll have to pull
it off
yeah to make sure which picture well of
him of his dad oh yeah yeah yeah yeah or
his dad okay
so i'm just helping you no i appreciate
it i appreciate you looking out
all right all right so quarter black yes
is going to when did we go out did i
already set up the story before
that we might interesting all right okay
marley was dead to begin with
really hunter biden n-word n-word edward
white lawyer said it no one in the media
cares i don't know how to pronounce the
lawyer's name quite literally
because i haven't seen the story covered
anywhere so i've only read it
i'm going to go with mysteries
i'm going to go with this shopkin geoj
miss series hmm he's a lowly
boring figure so uh hunter biden
repeatedly said the n word don't care i
don't think that he said it in a
i shouldn't say i don't care i don't
think that he's this doesn't make him
hateful toward black people i think his
classes
yes i think he's classes there you go
dave that's it
pedophile feet uh having sex with his
knees flipper grandkids okay good
computer
you can go to club if you want to see
more of it there you go so the text
which we cannot read but quarterback
garrett can read
quarterback garrett will read the text
from hunter biden to his lawyer show him
a picture
in case this was missed uh this is my
dad of your dad to prove
that he got a little ethnicity in you
yep
yep yeah yep he got some college grants
yep i got that
all right all right let me put these are
the texts and dave will be playing the
role of a lawyer i guess
we want some music kick it yeah
there you go a little lower just to
confirm uh
this is hunter biden's text yeah it's
just to confirm yeah these are
hunters yes
we would never say this more than likely
except chris when doing story prep
right yeah so i've never seen this
purely educational
repeating hunter bite i just want to be
really clear because i wouldn't want to
offend any i wouldn't because it's very
i don't want your first words they don't
want you to
it's pretty i don't want you guys to
think that because i wouldn't does it i
just yeah that wouldn't be you that okay
it's a guy who is free based cheese yes
yeah sure and he's strip cracker he's a
crackhead
and he said this yeah that was him all
right here we go first one
[ __ ] you better not be charging me
hennessy rates
oh i didn't know that's what we were
talking about that's racist no this is
these are the actual that's the actual
text that's the
you can look on the map right the first
one we'll get to oh yeah i'll read the
other ones then that's not
i didn't get those ones okay do you have
the actual do you have the full text
here i've got the full text here do you
have the lawyer responded i've got the
lawyer response all right
re read all of it okay okay omg [ __ ]
did you just fictional these are crack
infused okay yeah
did you just fictional character from
the imagination of the collective
frightened and my dead brother's
unconditional love is what i should rely
on and my kids aren't
children george the most defensive
confusion the most offensive part of
this
is the sentence structure and that
someone unknowingly would read this and
assume that it's a black person writing
it
and it's definitely not it's no it's
it's a white person perpetuating a
negative stereotype you
you'd see it you'd say oh this is the
word of course they're black this is
horrible we need a bet we need better
educational systems in the inner cities
no it's a white guy who's smoking parm
or a or a soft gouda
this next one's this next one's not too
bad he's trying to act like he's sober
right he's like it's unconditional love
i found god okay i don't think you have
oh and he also says [ __ ] so true that
[ __ ] yeah at the end yeah
oh yeah that's hunter this is all hunter
biden i know this lawyer is like eight
hundred dollars an hour and it's still
not worth it
the next one here oh it says there's
zero from hunter's lawyer there's
zero coverage or pickup of this story
zip i believe talking about the
laptop yeah uh to which hunter replied
wow
thank you michael cohen and then uh
other texts here other texts of red i'm
sorry for sexting you accidentally that
was meant for another friend named
george georgia
uh he also says my penis of late has
been unconditional
whatever that means and then uh it's a
big penis george
i only love you because you're black
yeah which is look well i guess that's
sort of reverse that's racism it's weird
yeah that's love
right yeah it's love so we can give them
the best love it throws you off with the
repeated use of the n-word i guess
but uh hey you know what they say with
this obviously i want to be clear
uh it's not his fault like father like
son
[Music]
since we went back to youtube did we
lose questions
ditch that face not out of a liberal
instinct for love brother and humanity
although i think that's a
good instinct but for simple pragmatic
reasons
if we don't they will or a portion of
them will
become the predators 15 years from now
what
my son is attorney general a year in
iraq came back and that's one of the
things that he finds is was most in need
when he was over there in iraq for a
year people would come to him
and talk about what was happening at
home in terms of foreclosures in terms
of
bad loans that were being i mean these
shylocks and
advantages in its racist context
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids
7-11 or a dunkin donuts unless you have
a slight
indian accent it's absolutely am i'm
i mean you got the first sort of
mainstream african-american yeah
who was articulate and bright and and
clean and nice looking i'm just so mad
he's
incorrect uncle phil uncle phil [ __ ]
right
he's like yeah come on by far by
far i love how he follows it up i'm not
joking and i'm like oh
that is a story now yeah we weren't
going to say you were joking you were a
joke literally i'm not
like when robert byrd said the uh the n
word two times and he was saying he got
a lot of white n words i've seen white
n words in my day to insult them yeah
and then his correction was like i'm
sorry i used language that uh
you know i understand is nola is
offensive to some and no longer perfect
well it's offensive because you designed
it as an offensive term right exactly
because you're
denigrating black people and saying some
white people are so lowly as black
people like where does that come from
like no i'm not i'm not cop i'm not a
tributing motive there
you filibuster the civil rights act for
like 12
14 hours and you're still sticking a
landing with the n word the point is
like father like son joe biden take him
at his word he's not joking
i still don't think that they should be
canceled for raising
as much as the you know pedophilia yeah
well that seems fair
it's a tear yeah a little higher than
that and there are other we have
actually obtained two some others some
exclusive texts
uh here yeah from from uh hunter so i
believe you have them here
yeah and quarterback of course again
show your father i just make sure just
give me one second here yeah just for
people who don't know
banners right here you know yeah right
there and get that banner there because
we do have exclusive text and it's just
we got to make sure that we're
covered so it doesn't get taken out of
context so quarter black reads other
hunter biden texts that we have the
exclusive on these
yes here we go let me let me bring it up
i don't know if you can see them because
they're gonna be covered
yeah no it's good hunter biden says uh
uh
what up my [ __ ] where you at and the
response says expected arrival time 15
minutes
i need that [ __ ] homie i'm feeling sick
expected arrival time 14 minutes
can't you speed [ __ ] and it says your
your door dash has been canceled yo he's
hungry though i mean
these are tough if you're hungry it's
almost like it's his mo
it's hard yeah uh well you can't expect
that you two can you could you two i
guess can do the can this necromancer
and we have these exclusive all our
sources are available
yeah i'll give this one so this is
haunter quarter black uh hunter let me
go to the next one here
uh [ __ ] i have a fever
and the chill is it covered honey i've
told you a million times
i'm not a real doctor oh well sorry mom
sorry mom
that's another bender oops true because
she's not and then this one i can
this one is actually pretty rough i
guess it says here it was to kamala
and he just said yo i just smoked
one of your cookies and this [ __ ] is uh
flame emoji flame emoji flame emoji
oh i gotcha okay all right yeah
so it just seemed that one's more tone
deaf it really yeah
and outwardly racist he really shouldn't
just smoke everything that's handed to
him no
that's not a good idea it's hard to tell
though with the crack
right yeah it's true trying poor guy's
running out of carpeting
it's like pookie and new jack it's like
you gotta have it
you gotta do something else with your
time uh and this is another one we have
an exclusive here uh number four here
quarter black garrett this is uh
uh oh yeah yeah that he was texted first
right the text came to him and it said
uh save ten percent
uh come to chili's with discount code
seven eight nine nine today tonight only
uh you better not be charging me that
hennessy rates [ __ ]
and then uh cheerleading dear god is
this joe biden's son hunter
oh so i don't know how that works with
an auto yeah
it must be like a you know he does it a
lot well yeah but he's known at chili's
and there's like a dozen from sunglass
hut he's known as chili's though yes
he he's inappropriate with the waiters
he's a regular at chili's
i guess this is the last one right this
one was the last one
you know this perhaps a smoking gun he
was texting his father too
the big man yeah and so uh he texted his
father
uh hey dad where are you at keep you the
where do you keep the spray key and then
uh
former vice president said who this uh
it's me dad
i need a key and then former vice
president said to fix to fix the pool
pump
damn dad you gotta old as hell i can't
read man
it's me that banner doesn't help you
it's me yo
and then that just says oh hey hunter i
got a very small screen so it seems like
everyone kind of identifies him
hmm you don't know it's him because of
the way he's unless he's racist
like if he walked into a room and spoke
normally they'd be like i don't know if
he'd be like no no
it's me hunter n word like oh there you
are hunter
it's like if the weather just spray
painted that word on the wall of every
house they robbed right that's a card
card right yeah and there's been no
coverage of this of course you can get
rid of that banner since i'm not you
uh i'm sure though remember here's the
thing remember
can you just imagine and i don't just
want to do what about ism but the
treatment from the media
if we if someone happened to get my
phone
and this is what i was texting for no
reason you know what i'm
junior yeah or if it was john junior are
you kidding me well because they were
going after don junior for
remember trevor noah tweeted a racist
cokey don jr is now lecturing us about
about racist cookies june 29th bernie
sanders tweeted donald trump jr is a
racist too
shocker jake tapper blatantly called
donald jr
blatantly racist right okay well where's
the coverage here the guy who used the
n-word
in its racist context who by the way
comes from the lineage of a man who uses
racial pejoratives in their racist
context yeah
that's all i'm saying do me a favor just
prove to me that you're a journalist
without any bias like you claim on every
show
right just report on this it's news
right yeah
it's got to be newsworthy somebody's
talking about it why don't you cover it
at least people are being honest with
this where they're going like
uh like now you have liberals going like
oh like you've never uh texted something
like that with your friends you know
joking about hip hop's like aha exactly
that's what we've been saying this whole
time
you've come full circle you've come how
i circled everyone
yeah what people say it doesn't matter
no this matters because it's controlling
of language
yeah it's controlling of speech it's
again it's barring
one half of the country from speaking
from having a voice at the table
whether it's about whether it's doctors
about covid whether it's economists
about lockdowns whether it's professors
about
racial theory whether it's professors
like jordan peterson
against language laws whether it's
speaking out against black lives matter
against the world health organization
the point is it's all about controlling
what you can and can't say
and so when you have people of course
accuse donald trump jr
of being racist and by the way they love
to bring up the fact that he you know
that he
uh does coke the guy was an alcoholic
has been very open about it and he's
been sober for years
it's always a funny thing how the left
wants to talk about mental health and
how we need to be more open about it we
have a mental health issue in this
country
and they're so quick to weaponize it
sort of like the gay thing right
homosexuality
like there's nothing wrong with it like
oh yeah secret he spoke to god secretly
you want to put for peter
well look i don't wait how is that an
insult there's nothing wrong with being
gay
that means if nothing else that you
think have a slightly better fashion
sense than i thought
yes they weaponize sexuality and they
immediately this is what they do
they weaponize addiction mental health
when they can use it
that's why you have a sexuality issue
that's why
you have a mental health issue well they
tried to paint donald trump and trump jr
as racist and said see
here is the evidence yeah if you use
these terms you are a racist and they
did it just to try to paint him that way
so that they could get him out of office
and now when the shoe's on the other
foot they're like well no it's totally
fine that joe biden to be fair with
hunter biden his shoes are always on the
other foot well it's true
two left yeah sometimes it's his niece's
shoes
well they barely fit i told her to get
bigger feet
i can't wait to them i like him i like
small feet well then she would be that's
what he likes he likes small feet
he's in he has texts about don't even
get me started on the chinese football
no
it's a whole other thing not even it's
bananas it is absolutely
bonkers alcoholism has always been
something that people have
usually to cover another mental illness
whatever that is depression whatever it
may be
so the fact that they were well no i
meant
well no he's trying to drink those
thoughts away i i was more talking about
the trump guy i'm not defending
oh oh yeah never mind because he's still
currently doing that
yeah well i you know there's a big
difference between a guy going
every everything i saw i just smoked
parmesan cheese right right lady
interviewing me
you've smoked cheese off your face the
carpet right and a guy who's like when i
used to drink i i used to have too much
yeah that's what it was so i decided to
change my life and be better yeah you
did a lot of drugs
did you ever consider smoking cheese or
any other uh perhaps snack foods
i did smoke a ritz cracker now hear me
out
i hear the story i did not know it was a
ritz cracker
oh i was very very drunk and my friend
john was upset at me
over something she was like hey i gave
you fur she's on this bong
and i was like oh cool so i hit it and
this beautiful white cloud filled the
bong
and then when i cleared the chamber it
was the most pain i've ever felt in my
throat
and it turned out that it was uh he had
stuffed a ritz cracker in it
oh wow yeah so you didn't seek out a
ritz cracker
no for a tasting as it were but it it
all worked out because his life is
really bad
is this the same friend you hid in the
face with a frozen sausage thinking it
was soft
no this is a different guy oh okay a
different guy no but he had
he was mad at me about something but it
was pretty funny i chased him around
and then i fell because i was drunk yeah
well i slipped that was foreseeable
i don't think i don't think that uh
reese's peanut butter cups foresaw
hunter biden when they came up with
their slogan there's no wrong way to eat
a reese's no no no no
no
the point about this right is when it's
selective coverage when it's not again
the rule is not do we have rule of law
or do we have rules it's are they
applied equally
that's when you're in a free society so
now we go north of the border to
canada to talk about something that many
people don't realize you only enjoy in
the united states the first amendment
protection of freedom of speech
so um canadian i don't know if this was
the uh
this monday uh i believe it was
uh canadian liberals voted to limit
debate on their uh this this bill
c10 it's an online censorship bill just
to be clear
wow so this is important because there's
a different tie in here a lot of times
you'll get people saying well you know
what uh the first amendment doesn't
guarantee you the right to say whatever
you want online
uh just guarantees the writing on the
town square well in a second if people
are
public if these these uh sites are our
public platforms like facebook twitter
youtube and they enjoy these legal
protections and financial
uh benefits then yeah then we are
talking about look if you're not free
to discuss issues online in the digital
public square
that's a problem especially now when you
see that there are governments we've
seen it with china and now we see it
with canada
where the governments have regulatory
control
over online speech that's why
you need states to start passing some
laws because other governments in the
world
they've already taken if there's going
to be a step in one direction or the
other
does the government tell you what you
can and can't say online still think
it's not a first amendment issue
or does the government tell these
huge platforms that they cannot dictate
which opinions are permissible online
there really is no in-between this is a
black or white issue
so conservatives um the new democratic
party and the green party opposed the
motion because
of an amendment in the bill that uh
gives the canadian radio television
communications
commission regulatory uh authority over
social media posts yeah to be clear when
people talk about government uh
as a community when people talk about
government media i'm not just talking
about pbs people talk about government
media like in venezuela you don't you
just go to canada
you just go to canada in the last
election i believe with trudeau i
believe there was a member i think it
was the ndp i can't remember exactly but
i know that someone promised
the cbc uh a hundred million dollars
in national funding and then i believe
it was trudeau promised 150 million
guess who won and guess who got the most
positive coverage when people say
the corporate media look i understand
believe me
watch right now on cnn okay all right
they're still talking about january 6th
like we just talked about
right now on cnn yeah they have a point
of view there's a buy and of course it's
tired
and i would say the same thing about fox
news i don't tune in but the good thing
is
at least there's cnn and fox news
exactly
and i and there is an imbalance of power
abc nbc cbs msnbc cnn
and then on cable only fox news and now
online
facebook twitter youtube apple amazon
and they want to make sure that all
conservative voices aren't allowed so
it's not perfect
that's why we just need rules and
regulations that ensure that people
are abiding by them and in this case
it's about government
reining in censorship coming from
companies because elsewhere in the world
governments are forcing companies to
censor and guess what
that affects what you say on these
platforms in the united states
because that can't reach people in
countries like china in places like the
uk
canada this is a very clear example you
can throw a baseball
for those of you who live in upstate new
york and uh
and hit where i grew up yeah well and
just so you know like this is done under
the guise of making big tech
corporations kind of pay their fair
share there and promote canadian content
so they're like
well that sounds good right like like
support our content oh
there's these other things over here
right and so of course uh uh
professional blackface and chief trudeau
uh i believe it's 19 times connoisseur
not just blackface
black arms the whole thing everything oh
no el jolson didn't wear as much black
face
if you had a delorean and could bring
the actual minstrel shows
to trudeau's high school talent show
they'd go oh that's severe
this is a bit much this is a bit much
we were just having a goof um so then
this last month trudeau responded to
conservative critics uh by accusing them
this is what happens right yeah you
guess oh
tin tinfoil hat crazies when
conservatives said
no the government shouldn't be able to
tell people what they're allowed to say
and not stay online
will the prime minister tell us how long
it will be before
every aspect of canadian life must
conform
to his liberal vision of canadian
society
the right honourable prime minister the
tin foil hats on the other side of the
aisle are really quite spectacular but
we will continue
to stand up to defend freedom of speech
stand against hatred and discrimination
and do it while supporting canadians to
both get through this like killing john
mcclane
that is our focus mr speaker the
conservatives can continue to focus on
me
we'll continue to focus on canadians
yeah you're just haters
focus on me yeah yeah i am rubber you
are glue hold on
i am rubber you are blue
this guy is so racist and such a piece
of [ __ ]
all right okay yeah there's really no
more to say i'm so ashamed of my
dual citizenship i'm so ashamed of
canada yeah there's so many things that
i would like to
that i would like to like about canada
and this guy makes it so hard
yeah okay you noticed he didn't refute
the argument no and let me be clear
freedom of speech does not exist in
canada it doesn't exist in the uk you
have people who were actually jailed for
doing a cover of kung fu fighting at a
karaoke bar
we've gone through all these stories
before all the sources are available at
rescuer.com the point that's important
here
is the language in this proposed bill
i'm going to read it for you directly
it's actually based on a supreme court
case
in canada that dick precedent matters
yeah that declared a pastor speaking out
against same-sex marriage
as hate speech so that's the grounds
right that's the basis for this ruling
going to apply it
wow online what do you think happens
when your american tweet
is in canada these are the complications
that occur
we'll get to them in a second
internationally so the court rule this
is the actual language
truthful statements can be presented in
a manner that would meet the definition
of hate speech let me read that again
truthful statements can be presented in
a manner
that would meet the definition of hate
speech it's insane
and not all truthful statements must be
free from restriction
what what that's just saying that you're
not allowed to tell the truth
yeah so if you tell if it offends people
exactly if you tell it
we don't like well no no it's not if it
offends people generally it's not like
they take a poll on what hate speech is
it's if this panel this tribunal that
we've set up says that it's hate speech
because they don't like your
truth they don't like the idea that
you're saying is true
yeah because the queen of shoeholish
might not like it
[Applause]
this is this is so this is what we talk
same when we talk about youtube with the
guidelines by the way best thing you can
do is comment
if you guys knew about this in canada
okay if you guys actually knew what's
going on there and you understand what
people say first amendment doesn't apply
no no
governments have regulatory control
right what happens online and
they've given freedoms again section 230
public utilities versus publisher
uh public for example sprint verizon at
t cannot tell you what you can or cannot
say on their phone lines
doesn't matter if you're wearing a white
hood that's an infringement of your
rights
and facebook twitter you they are
recognized the same way they are
afforded
the same legal protections this is
something that i think people don't
understand that the united states is the
only place where freedom of speech
actually exists and here's the big
problem too
with big tech and these rules okay so
let me
let me tell you a story youtube for
example
and yes yesterday's stream is not
available on youtube it is available at
mug club and on rumble if you guys want
to
make sure that you don't miss anything
um youtube has
community guidelines yeah okay then they
have
advertiser friendly guidelines right
okay different list
then they have borderline content
guidelines
three lists now here's the thing we
don't know who the advisors are in
advertiser guidelines
friendly guidelines i've been an
advertiser on youtube i've never once
been asked as a matter of fact i would
have said hey i don't want to run ads on
this content i would like to run ads on
the kind of content that you don't allow
um they deliberately don't tell you who
is in charge of borderline
yeah the only thing that they say is
very clear and transparent are community
guidelines
and those are not enforced equally
because when we've run afoul of
community guidelines we actually haven't
right they said well you said that the
office you praised the officer who shot
makai
bryant at that point and uh that's that
maybe isn't acceptable now here's the
thing
if you want to say okay all right they
have their own rules
i don't know i'm pro-business i'm not
pro-fraud now here's what i would say
when people say well where's the line
it's always a sliding scale
look at canada right it's nuanced no
it's not it's pretty simple
the line is what's legal right we have
that
you can say in the town square i don't
like i don't like jews like uh joe biden
you can call jews shylocks like joe
biden did it's horrible it's
reprehensible just quoting the fact i
was really mad that joe biden was doing
that in a public
forum yeah but he has the right to do it
he wouldn't have the right to say go
attack the shylocks
right he repeatedly used the word shylux
in races context okay just to be clear
and again we don't even know if the rule
will be applied equally here or youtube
gets mad at me and says oh we're going
to take you down for
quoting directly joe biden but the point
is
we have laws people say you can't yell
fire in a credit theater sure you can if
there's a fire
it's very very clear what is actually
legal and permissible
crimes are not calls to actions that are
violent or harm people deliberately
are not everything else is
or you lose your protection and your
legal status through section 230 here's
why this matters
youtube and facebook and twitter not
only
don't actually abide by the laws
of our country they flagrantly disregard
them
let me give you an example we did a
video a long time
ago in a single party consent state now
this is what matters right because
all journalists since the beginning of
time have to understand hey
uh can can we uh watergate or you know
whatever it is joe
take your donald trump donald trump grab
by the [ __ ] or scandal of our time next
to january 6th right
that was released why single party
consensus day maybe not they don't care
the media doesn't care
but the point is journalists have to
know single party consent means you can
record someone without them knowing
you are legally within your rights it's
very important to a democracy
into rooting out corruption i think
there are 11 states that are dual party
consent states which mean
means you can't do it we were in a state
single party consent state but we still
ask the person on camera to say
your name pronounce it and say and do
you give us permission to use
your image in this footage yes
youtube said they sent us a message
after they said they didn't want to be
on there so
we're going to take it down take back
they did take backs yeah
what and i think we ended up we had to
take it down at that point maybe we got
it back up and we blurred something but
yeah then they're not allowed
and they made it clear now in their new
community guidelines
that anything that should that shows
identi that it could potentially
identify somebody not doxing
show somebody's face you hear someone's
voice and they don't
like it your content will be removed
wow that goes against the law so here in
one side we have the laws
and by the way whether you agree with
the laws or not a little bit more went
into it
right then than susan ogitski just uh
you know running it out of thin air
you have the laws and you choose to
abide by the laws or you choose to abide
by incredibly opaque
social media guidelines now let's muddy
that with foreign governments
telling these social media platforms how
they have to censor
and they abide by it this is not this is
something that's often ignored
um let's use hong kong as an example
2019
chinese authorities uh they ordered
media to delete any social media posts
related to the protest as well as the
phrase
let's go hong kong many companies
obliged
uh the chinese music platform qq banned
the
les miz song do you hear the people sing
hmm
i thought before i thought it was just
russell crowe's version yeah well that's
true
well they're also anti-musical banned
that though yeah and the chinese
government of course used twitter and
facebook to spread propaganda alleging
the
the protests were perpetrated by thugs
funded by the cia and of course they
also used it to
uh promote the conspiracy theory that
coveted started
from american soldiers that's still up
by the way all sources available at
lottery credit.com
say hong kong thugs yes i saw that right
exactly oh wow it sounds like a sketch
doesn't it
hong kong so i just want people to
understand what's at stake whether
it's a private company if you don't like
it go start your own really
can i go start my own with billions of
dollars
in relief i got wires and liability
protection
under the guise of a lie
and do i have the canadian government
the chinese government
supporting me if favors exchange hands
this is the issue here right now
you see these laws in canada you see
these laws in the uk they are designed
to censor
content online remember jordan peterson
said look i'm not going to abide by this
it was
a pronoun law he said someone in my
class i'll be i'll be respectful
of course but i will not commit i will
not commit to abiding by language laws i
won't do that
because it's a slippery slope well now
you can't say things that are truthful
in canada online if they offend people
can i can we bring that back up
let me read this quote for you so people
liberals in the united states
say i'm pro-free speech but not if
someone says something offensive let me
read you the quote from the uh
the supreme court of canada what this is
based on
okay it's overlay i truthful statements
can be presented in a manner
that would meet the definition of hate
speech and not
all truthful statements must be free
from restriction
this is law in canada this is what
democrats want as
law in the united states this is insane
you have to pick a side
you have to pick a side does the
government exist to protect the people
does the government exist to serve the p
and by that i mean protect rights
this is a fundamental worldview and i'm
sorry guys i know i keep going off here
today
but look it should this is a
fundamentally different worldview
between
the right and the left unalienable
rights what does that mean gerald
enable you can't take the way they give
them to us exactly it means
that no rights are given to you by
government or by man it means you are
born
with rights and the government's job is
to make sure that no one infringes on
your god-given rights
whether it's the government or another
citizen notice that by the way
the constitution and constitutionalists
like myself you look at you say okay
what is unalienable means i'm born with
it so the law protects you
from both a corrupt government or from
or from citizens who might want to hurt
you if you exercise your first amendment
right
the second amendment right it protects
you from citizens who might want to hurt
you or invade your home
or the government now fundamentally
different worldview from that the left
says
we'll allow you to say this but not that
hey hey in germany right internet is the
internet is a human right
oh so we're just making up rights we're
just declaring it it sounds good people
go oh look for internet yeah i bet you
bernie sold that [ __ ] to you but guess
what
if someone makes up a right they can
take away a right that's
the point that's unalienable and when
you don't understand it's
versus right no it is it is it is
because this is a conservative country
we are trying to
in this country anyways conserve means
conserve the constitutional
ideas of rights that are not granted
by some [ __ ] blackface hack like
trudeau
they're your rights so you need to
decide right now as it relates to social
media as it relates to big tech as it
relates to 230.
does the government exist to protect
your god-given
natural right to freedom of speech both
from
themselves protects you from the
government of frigid and
from someone else like a corporation or
does the government
serve to grant you rights in which case
they in the big tet platforms are well
within their authority to say
you can say this you can't say that you
can say that about china you can't
protest in hong kong
even though that's true that's offensive
but you can say a lie
like you went to the border kamala
harris
it's an a or b decision exactly well and
you made a good point the other day when
we were talking about this you said in
in radio and in tv we know the rules the
fcc has guidelines for what you can and
can't say
and everybody knows those rules and you
can play by them they're set in stone
they've been thought through and if you
violate those rules you understand
what's going to happen
with big tech platforms we have no idea
you just listed off three sets of rules
that we were
hopefully we're going to read one of
these days on air and they
even in those rules they have caveats
that they can just pretty much do
whatever they want because they've done
it to us and so when these guys go out
and say well no look there's no
censorship we're applying the rules
equally okay
name me one liberal site that you've
taken down
and in front of congress they couldn't
do it right you know these things aren't
being equally applied and how is this
not like the mafia bosses
you're like oh well they didn't actually
commit the murder and they didn't
actually tell somebody to commit the
murder but she just knew what they
wanted to do well when big tech
basically goes out there
and does the bidding of democrats and
liberals
they do it for a reason guys they're
shutting down speech and i'm saying it
both ways i don't want a
republican-controlled
social media that kicks off all liberal
ideas i want both i want to be able to
point at your idea and say that's really
stupid
just be mitch mcconnell in a raggedy
address it was parlor
oh yeah but then that was taken down
from immediately the apps and not just
people say
go start your own okay we shot our own
oh we're gonna ban it from search and
from the app store
oh it's nice so you took it down
but that's supposed to be a free and
open source by the way too you don't
just take it down it's not violating
laws
i think the u.s exists though
specifically to protect your god-given
right effect
speech that's that's exactly why it
exists but you have to understand when
trudeau said that about the tin foil hat
people on the other side he said
we will continue to fight for free
speech okay trudeau do me a favor define
free speech and then he said and against
hate speech and discrimination right
again we know the law says
truth if it's offensive is not protected
speech there you go there you go there
you go
by the way it's just freedom like a
series of half truths yes
oh gosh i'm sorry i forget you're from
canada you don't know what freedom is
yeah you don't
okay i'm sorry you don't get it you get
to say hey why
why in america why do you have so many
guns up there [ __ ] well let me tell you
exactly why
so we're not you and so we never become
you because you're everything that we
hate
you kneeled and kissed the ring
we fought them off twice and then we
said we have to make sure
hey and kate hey hey canada where are
you [ __ ] boom no no look jab
in case you guys try and become another
colony
and take us over because you're right
there we're going to make sure we have
guns so canada
stay in line that's why we have guns
why does japan not have guns look at the
atrocities committed against their own
people
yeah they created a culture of
subservience i'm not saying it's
inferior
i'm saying it's not our culture we are a
culture
of renegades and rebels and you may not
like it
but there's every other country that
exists for you yeah
this is the only one that has that this
is the only one that has the first
amendment
just go so it's a much more valid
argument when uh
conservatives say if you don't like it
leave then when a liberal says it
because a conservative can go nowhere a
liberal if you look at their policies
if you look at kamala harris and joe
biden's policies how they match up
they would be happier if our if our
country was canada they would be happier
if our country
well not mexico because their
immigration was incredibly racist france
norway denmark they would be happier
if the united states was any other
country
the reason that conservatives are so
passionate is this is the only place
left where are we going to go
going to go to canada where prime
minister blackface says you can't tell
the truth if it offends the wrong person
and just in case you think oh the online
world the digital world is separate from
the real world
i i think people don't understand that
they are one and the same and that's
also why you need to be very prudent
about what you post online especially
this generation because
you search for a job it's always going
to come up but to show you that the real
world
and the online world meet up just look
at the enforcement
of canada a lot of people think free
well tell me if you think this seems
free
canada's draconian coveted laws some of
which were enforced
because they were tipped off by social
media
clip f you don't respect the curfews
then just for everybody
and you really think so communism is
going to help eh
[Music]
arresting people for curfew
[Music]
breaking up a church please get out get
out of this property immediately not
today satan
is not allowed here immediately gestapo
is not
allowed so go
go he doesn't come back
i guess i didn't need a warrant because
it's canada that's resting
that's going to scuff up the shoes look
at that come on oh the nice cordovan
oh loafers i like those loafers sir i
got you there my god thank you
arrested these are italian game on you
guys
hey and by the way wow i think we all
agree the nazi comparison is overused
but i think we all agree m isn't fake i
think
but if you wouldn't consider it a legit
if it's not a legitimate comparison to
use the gestapo
for government authorities entering a
place of worship to shut you down due to
arbitrary laws
being created in the name of your own
health hint by the way
look at what the nazis said about the
jews big part of it we're health reasons
yeah
if that's not a valid comparison to the
gestapo then you can
never use it no you can't you should
really never use it anyway but that is
the exact thing they were doing yes
they went and they were looking for
people you see they were searching for
people yeah and you pulled them out and
arrested them yes
for worship yeah don't think don't think
gestapo like right around 1940 think
gestapo essentially like 1935.
yeah think about how it gets started but
yeah you haven't done yourself like
like when the beatles were still in
elvis cover bran cover band yeah yeah
bridge invasion having happened
you could see the seedlings they were
still doing that stuff say what you will
about the nazis well-dressed right
yeah good job know just saying you could
see the ceiling like in
35 they're like you know he hasn't
killed you know he hasn't killed his
first jew but
i i know one day that man will make a
fine gestapo as if somebody only liked
my pain
one day he will make his father very
proud yeah
do you remember the video of them
arresting a kid for skating on ice
yeah are you scared just down a pond
away from everyone
just skating and they're like oh we're
gonna have to arrest you and he's like
well here's the thing
is that all that dissimilar when people
say that could never happen here
governor whitmer
wanted to arrest people wanted to arrest
people for going out in a boat with a
motor row boat's fine
a boat with a motor and remember there
was a sheriff from leelanau county
michigan who said
look if people are being if people are
being
ruthlessly unsafe i'll tell them but i'm
not going to find them or put them in
jail right and he was vilified the only
reason she didn't do it
is because we do have some
constitutional protection so that has
been pushed to its absolute limits well
there was a
lady who opened her hair salon in dallas
texas that was arrested early on right
about the same time that nancy pelosi
was going to get her blow out in a
private salon in san francisco we have
footage from that didn't the woman in
san francisco get in a lot of trouble
too
yeah because nancy pelosi said she was
set up set up oh yeah
i was set up and i didn't like the hair
how long would it take to make that
[ __ ] look good
the vortex ever somebody was arrested i
mean and you say this is
a republican kind of stronghold right
we've got governor abbott here
and in these students liberal yes stupid
stupid liberal
cities like dallas and houston and san
antonio
you've got people that were arrested for
opening their business
that's not that far that goes back to
the world view where in the constitution
does it say that you have a right to a
deep perm
it doesn't it says that the government
doesn't have the right to tell me
anything that isn't outlined here yeah
it doesn't need to say d perm for the
same reason it doesn't need to say
first amendment applies to the printing
press
exactly okay what you said with jewish
people in the holocaust this
they used health which is the number one
thing you can use
to scare the [ __ ] out of it sorry pardon
my language but it is upsetting to scare
the crap out of people
i think i've dropped an f-bomb when i
was mad at trudeau earlier and i'm about
to do it again because i can see out of
the corner of my eye
fauci is there he's there but i don't
know if we have the 10-second delay so
i'm just going to do with my mind right
now he's got no things don't hold him
down
ironic isn't it ironic that we said he
looked like a puppet is an actual puppet
yeah he really is
china hey steven uh still an
authoritative source an authoritative
source
oh by the way hey hold on a second bring
him up he looks tired you know what i
mean like he's run out of poddlings
yeah oh yeah he does look like he was
interested
by jim henson doesn't he that's that's
like you right out of the pod
crystal like yeah you'd fish him out of
the junk drawer in jim henson's workshop
yeah the less magical part of the
workshop my final thing here i want you
guys hey smash that like button if
you're watching on youtube again we're a
live show monday through thursday
10 am eastern smash the like button hulk
oh that's the rumble bug
that's fine too on youtube you can smash
the like button and comment below here's
something that i would love and i i'm
not doubled i will do this
i'm not saying that i will do this okay
but considering the fact that we have
talked about refugees
for example like we've talked about
syrian refugees when like 90
of them were uh military aged men yeah
muslim men not the christians who are
being murdered right
right say refugees they're well they're
leaving because they don't like that
country because it sucks
right a middle a young muslim man is not
being persecuted there for their
religious beliefs
no look in mexico we say these people
are seeking asylum refugees
well let me just be really clear it's
it's just not a very good country and
what i mean by that there's not a lot of
opportunity
poverty people are starving but they're
not being persecuted for their religious
beliefs in mexico right that's what we
need to talk about with asylum
that's the term for refugee i think that
conservative canadians would have a more
legitimate claim to asylum to escape the
united states right now
considering that they can actually be
arrested and fined
simply for attending their place of
worship so i don't know if there's a
lawyer out there if someone can start a
gofundme to just bring as many
not illegal migrants many of that asylum
seekers over from canada
and buy some acreage up there in
michigan but i would love to see that
happen because what are you going to do
deport them racism much i don't think
that that i don't think that dog will
hunt all right listen we have to go to
uh mug club here well what is going on
right now
oh fauciano's work against the aids
epidemic because brilliant work
yeah does that mean attending bath
houses and then telling people that
uh heterosexual couple 20 million people
would die of aids before the year i
believe 1992.
presenting it as if it's this is a good
thing yeah like no there's no
accountability it was wrong then
presenting the way he did to the towel
boy right
hey if they were being outlet they would
say hey talk about how 40 years ago
you also got everything wrong yeah
yeah you're really it's really good that
you're the go-to every time yes
i'll give you the next five minutes i
know it'll take some time you seem way
off on everything you want a job
yeah i see you again in 40 years hey you
were totally off on
age which affected a very small
percentage of this country meaning if
you were a heterosexual
mostly monogamous couple you had a
statistical zero chance of getting aids
that we told everyone that that they did
as though all of their behaviors were
were the same that led the same kind of
health or immune outcomes hey
um how about we do it now when we put
you in charge of a virus that can affect
everybody yeah i like it i'll do it
better you know what that's true because
my
virology with the bass houses was a
little esoteric it was a little niche
i would like to have control over a
general populace
no one loves anything as much as i love
that
lens
it's so beautiful and i like the bath
houses we can wear masks yeah we can
play masks
so that people you know we'll have them
down here instead of up here
like the eyes wide shut parties also
maybe down the line
then we can introduce the handcuffs
we'll find a reason they'll be
self-sanitizing handcuffs there you go
i'm an idea man i'm an idea man see like
why don't we feed the tuna
mayonnaise note to self cole starkist
all right hey
uh youtube thank you love you we're
going to mug club only but we don't
really love youtube you can uh you can
piss off